UYANGA TSEDEV: So hi, girls.
My name is Uyanga.
And I am currently
at the MIT Koch
Institute, which is a building
just for cancer research.
And today, I'm
going to talk about
the biological engineering
that we do in order to find
and image deeply embedded and
difficult-to-reach tumors.
So currently in the clinic,
the number one therapy method
for cancer is-- thank
you-- for cancer
is surgical debulking, which is
basically removing of the tumor
masses, and then chemotherapy.
And so it's very
important for surgeons
to be able to locate
precisely and early
on in the stage of the
tumor the masses that they
want to remove in order to do
the most effective therapy.
And so cancer
cells are basically
cells that have unusual
dividing abilities.
So they proliferate
without stop.
And they are differentiated from
the regular cells around them
by certain markers on
the surface of the cell.
And so what we want to do is
use these markers on the surface
in the cell in order to
find and then locate where
the tumors are, and
tell the surgeons,
this is the place
where you should
remove the biological tissue.
And you don't want to damage
the healthy tissue around it.
So you want to be very precise.
So there are two tools
that we use in our lab
in order to find the
tumors in the body.
The first is the
custom-built imager
that we're working on with
collaboration at the Lincoln
Labs, and the second is
the biological probe.
It's a little shuttle
that we use in order
to go ahead and find
the cells in the body.
So we can talk about
both of them today.
So the biological
marker that we use
is called the M13 bacteriophage.
And bacteriophage really
just means bacteria eater.
So it's a virus.
So as with typical viruses, it
infects bacteria, [INAUDIBLE]
takes over the local
mechanism of the bacteria,
and begins to replicate itself.
So what we can do
is hack this system
in order to use this molecule
for our own benefits.
It's a very beautiful, very
simple sort of molecule.
It's just a piece
of DNA-- so a DNA
that codes for its
genetic information--
and a bunch of proteins that's
wrapped around the body.
And so because we can
manipulate the DNA,
we can change the peptides that
are on the body of the phage.
And so we can change
the protein so that they
have specific binding
abilities to certain materials
or certain ligands,
or certain markers.
So this is the tumor cell
markers that I'm talking about.
We can change the protein
at the head of the virus
in order to bind specifically
to the surface of a cancer cell.
And we can change the
proteins on the body
of the virus to bind to
a specific imaging agent
or therapy agent that
we can then shuttle
to the surface of our cells.
So for our system here, the
imaging agent that we chose
is called a carbon nanotube.
And so a carbon nanotube
is just a piece of graphene
that's been rolled up.
And what graphene
is is it's just
a single layer of graphite.
And graphite is what you find
in your pencils, in lead.
And so it has very interesting
optical and electrical
properties, and it's
very well-studied.
But for us, what's
interesting about
it is the wavelength at
which it emits light.
This is in the second window
near infrared wavelength.
And so it's slightly longer
than the visible wavelength.
And the cool thing about this
is it's able to penetrate deeper
into the biological tissue.
And you have less scattering
and less interference
from the surrounding materials.
So finally, this is the
design of our shuttles
that we send in to
find tumor cells.
We have the M13
bacteriophage, which
has a particular
protein at the head that
detects the tumor cells.
And we have on the body the
CNT, the carbon nanotube,
that is going to
light up and tell us
this is where we should go
ahead and remove the mass.
So the first model that we
have actually done in our lab
is on ovarian tumor.
And ovarian tumor is one
of the tumor [INAUDIBLE]
that is very difficult
to detect early on.
Unlike things like breast
tumor, you can't feel it.
And usually when the surgeon
or the doctor diagnoses,
it's quite late in the
stage of the tumor.
So it could have
turned metastatic.
And metastatic means
that the tumor cells
have detached from
the body and traveled
to other parts of the body, and
so proliferated other tumors
throughout the body.
So this is a stage you
don't want to reach.
So it'd be very cool if you
can put our probes into mice
with a ovarian tumor,
light up the tumors,
give the surgeon the
image, and the surgeon can
go ahead and remove the tumors,
and the mice will then survive.
So this is a first step
in putting our system
to its clinical application.
So this is what
happens in real life.
You see here the stomach
cavity of the mice.
And in the bright orange,
you see all the tumor masses
that have lit up.
So we have injected
the mice with trillions
of our tiny little
molecular shuttles
that carry our CNT to the
location of the tumor.
And using our imager, which
we have built with help
from the Lincoln
Labs, the surgeon
is able to go in and
remove all these nodules.
And the cool thing
about the nodules
here is we're getting
the ones that are even
below a millimeter in diameter.
So usually, when a surgeon
goes in without any guidance,
he might miss these because
he's just going by eye.
But because he
has the imager, he
can go ahead and remove
most of the tumors.
So here's an example of what
we're doing in real time.
So during surgery, if
the surgeon can directly
refer to the images
that he's getting,
then he can go ahead and
implement our technology
in a very real way.
So here, we see Dr.
[INAUDIBLE] from MGH.
He's doing surgery on mice.
And you can see on the screen,
he can see brightly lit up--
this is where the
tumors are, and this
is where I should take it out.
And so here's a serial
image of what's happening.
So here's the probes lighting
up where the tumors are.
This is what happens when
the surgeon goes in by eye
and is like, OK,
from my experience,
this is where I should
take out the tumors.
And you see that there's
quite a bit of mass left.
But if we have the
imager, then we
have a much cleaner image
at the end of the surgery.
And so there's a
lot less of a chance
that the tumor is
going to recur.
So for me personally, there are
two things I'm doing in order
to expand on our system
that we have already built.
The first is manipulating
the M13 phage
to different geometries.
So I call this inhophage.
Inho just means
small in Portuguese.
And so based on the aspect
ratio, which basically
is the diameter versus
the length of our phage,
they might have very
different traveling abilities
in the bloodstream.
So because of
their oblong shape,
they have a tendency to stick
to the walls and tumble around.
But if we can change this
shape to an optimal size,
then there's a
chance that they will
travel for a longer period
of time in the bloodstream,
and so find the tumors
that are farther
from the site of injection.
The second thing is we are
expanding on the library
of cancers that we can attack.
So so far, we have
looked at ovarian tumor,
and now we want to
look at brain tumor.
And the most difficult
thing about brain tumor
is the blood-brain barrier.
So it's just a layer of cells
that separate your blood
from the matter in your brain.
And the molecules
that pass through
are very specific
and very small.
So it's very hard to deliver
from your bloodstream
various drugs or imaging agents
to the actual brain mass.
So what we have done
here is actually
engineer the head
peptides-- so the proteins
at the head of our phage--
so that it allows for travel
across the blood-brain barrier
so it can deliver these imaging
molecules to tumors
in the brain.
So one thing to remember here
is that the scale at which we're
working is very, very small.
So if you look at
CNT or our phage,
really, it's about
100,000 times smaller
than a strand of your hair.
So these are really,
really tiny things.
So when I make
these small phage,
they're even smaller
than our regular phage.
Our regular phage is
about 800 nanometers.
So here's an example of 280
nanometer phage, 100 nanometer
phage, and 50 nanometer phage.
So when I make them and
I want to look at them,
it's really hard because
they're so small.
And you can't just use
regular light microscopy
to detect them.
So another interesting
thing that I do
is use atomic force microscopy.
I don't know if
you've heard of it.
But what it is is basically
you take a sample,
and you have this
very, very tiny needle
that scans across the surface.
And so you're getting a
topology of the surface.
And from that scanning, kind
of like reading Braille,
you get a good idea of what
the profile of your image is.
So these are the images that
I get from this sort of needle
probing.
For the brain tumor,
another interesting factor--
not only can we bring
the phage to the surface
of the tumor-- so this is
tumor here shown in green.
This is tumor that actually
has green fluorescent proteins,
so that means they glow.
And if we send in our
phage, we see that, oh,
yeah, our phage goes ahead
and coats in red the tumor.
But then the other
thing we notice
is that the phage is actually
internalized into the tumor
cells.
So the phage comes and
attaches to the surface,
and then the tumor
cells eats the phage.
So in the blue here is
the nucleus of a phage.
And in the red spread around
the nucleus in the Golgi region
is our phage.
So it just tells us we can
possibly deliver things to
inside the cells of the cancer.
So that means we could
send in therapies
that disrupt the function,
and so in this way,
kill the tumor cells.
And so can we not only
detect where they are
and see if it can
remove them effectively,
but we can also
locally cure them.
So overall, today, we've looked
at the very real medical impact
that we can do with
imaging and the probe
that we have biologically
engineered in our lab.
And the two things
that I've done
is look at what we can do
to change the geometry,
and what we can do to change
the different cancers that we
can attack.
And all of this
work, of course, is
impossible without
the collaboration that
happens between the colleagues I
have at the MIT Koch Institute,
as well as the scientists
we have at the Lincoln Labs.
And so that's another really
cool thing about this project.
It's so very broad,
and so it brings
in so many different
techniques and brings
in so many different people.
And so I really
want to thank them.
And another aspect of this work
that I really find meaningful
is that I am personally
funded by families
that are affected by
these types of tumors,
these types of diseases.
And so I really want to thank
the Goodwin, [INAUDIBLE],
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
families who have been really
generous with their
funding for this project.
And finally, I want to say
that for me, the M13 is
kind of a building block.
We're here all as
Girls Who Build.
And so for me, for my building
project, it's the M13.
And I hope that you guys are
able to understand from this
that as an engineer,
for me, it's really just
about finding creative ways to
use my building blocks to make
a difference, to address
the problems that I think
are most important to me.
And so thank you very
much for listening.
Please feel free to
ask me any questions.
I can talk more about myself, or
I can talk more about research.
But yes, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Any
questions for her?
UYANGA TSEDEV: Yes?
AUDIENCE: You were
using specific examples
for the cancer, but can these
detect any type of cancer,
or is it just specific,
or a couple of types?
UYANGA TSEDEV: It can
detect any type of cancer
as long as you have a specific
differentiating marker
on the cancer that you know of.
So not only is this
useful in cancer,
it's also useful in
detecting any other material.
As long as you're able
to modify the head so
that it is specific to that
material or to that cell,
then you can do that, which
makes it a very elegant, very
cool molecule, which is
why I think it's something
I should be using.
[CHUCKLING]
PROFESSOR: Any other questions?
Great.
Thank you, Uyanga.
[APPLAUSE]
UYANGA TSEDEV: Thank you.